Vsauce Kevin here for almost 3,000 years
the cure-all for any medical ailment was
bleeding it was believed that being sick
was due to an imbalance of the four
humors blood phlegm black bile and
yellow bile so whether someone had a
seizure or a fever they thought it was
due to having too much blood and
therefore had to remove some by cunning
at the elbow or letting leeches suck it
out George Washington died after half of
his blood was removed as treatment for a
severe sore throat
trepanning is the oldest surgical
procedure we have archaeological
evidence of and it consists of drilling
a hole in the skull it was often
performed for medical purposes to cure
migraines epileptic seizures and even
mental disorders by means of releasing
the evil spirits trapped in the head in
the 60s Dutchman Bart Hughes performs
self trepanation using an electric drill
and advocated others to do the same in
order to increase the volume of brain
blood and reach a higher state of
consciousness a claim to which the
scientific community said no the enema
has also been around for thousands of
years being mentioned in detail on
ancient Egyptian papyrus circa 1600 BC
the rectal purge was performed using
hollowed-out
animal bones attached to liquid filled
gourds and were purported to cure
everything from the common cold and
allergies to headaches 17th century
France became so obsessed with internal
cleansing some had three or four animals
a day and King Louie the 14th is said to
have had thousands even receiving enemas
while hanging out with his buddies when
the Great Plague of London hit in 1665
attempted remedies included tobacco
smoke which led to children being
instructed to smoke in school rooms to
passing gas in a jar and then smelling
it because they believed foul smells
caused the plague and they could fight
it off with foul smells
their own and as always oh thanks for
watching
you